ce serait et maquettes nom est michael
kay bon dos et tout ce qui est magique
alors les gars aujourd'hui on se
retrouve pour une nouvelle vidéo j'ai
découverte ya pas très longtemps et je
sais pas j'ai eu un coup de coeur pour
cette banale je trouve drôle et et elle
a énormément font parfois même les pieds
ça ne paraissait pour toucher son public
à les sensibiliser sur des thématiques
un peu plus compliqué vraiment moi je
crois que je n'aurais pas très pratique
ce sera avec isabelle morini bosc
parce qu'en fait elle m'a toujours
fasciné depuis des années à avoir un
avis sur tout et je pense qu'on pourrait
faire des dîners ultra intéressant on
refait le monde parce que je trouve
qu'elle est grave
intéressant tout le temps me manque mais
j'ai toujours dit à mon entourage
isabelle suis sûr que je pourrai a parlé
d harry kewell une fois j'avais fait un
premier rendez vous avec une fille et
j'ai un de mes potes qui s'est greffé à
notre table et en fait ils attendaient
quelqu'un et la personne pomme avait des
labels du retard c'est du beau match car
je veux faire chier ville et il sait
ramener il a dit et sinon tu en penses
quoi toi des plans à trois j'étais comme
ça j attendais tétouan et bref
il a fait une 4ème au port parce que je
fais des mises à jour de la société un
peu comme sur nos téléphones quand on
voit les trois jours le logiciel mal
c'est un peu la même chose depuis 2015
pour ce qu'on a connu des vignes
j'aimerais bien venir porter spectacle
j'ai un peu peur dont je voulais savoir
est ce qu'un vigile qui fouillent les
sacs à l'entrée on a pas mal évolué
rapport à l'autre et aussi dans les
médias etc
je dresse cette mise à jour